so der letzte wurf von mario beck tritt
man sagen hatte auch schon mit einer
person des anderen geschlechts die
kleidung muss man sich an ein muss das
kleid jahr anziehen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab os bekommen bei einem
neuen video der leute wenn ihr die
letzten videos von mir gesehen habe dann
wisst ja ich bin momentan total im dart
fieber nein eigentlich habe ich absolut
keine ahnung davon aber es macht sehr
viel spaß viel zu werfen und ich bin auf
die idee gekommen und zwar gibt es ja
auf youtube oder generell wahrheit oder
pflicht stelle nicht kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch ist auch
schon extrem verein hat jeder gefühl
schon 27 mal gemacht nur wir machen das
heute in der daad version ja prominente
unterstützung von marie danke dass du
dabei bist heute ich zeige euch mal ganz
kurz unsere dartscheibe der wir sind
heute wieder draußen weil es so schön
warm ist immer dabei hat die sonne rein
da nicht sein deswegen habe ich hier
diese wand aufgestellt habe mir ganz
viele verschiedene möglichkeiten das
schwarze ist immer wahrheit und das rote
ist pflicht das heißt dort wo der fall
landet das muss man dann machen wenn man
jetzt nichts trifft zum beispiel der
fall landet hier dann muss man leider
noch mal werfen
also gibt es nicht jeden tag ist es
absolut wünschte 35 grad im schatten
heute ist es absolut wendig und auch für
30 grad im schatten
na ja anfangen einfach wenn ihr die idee
cool findet last auf jeden fall jetzt
schon mal auch noch oben da natürlich
wir werfen genau auf den sitzen von hier
aus ist alles verstanden warte warte da
kann man gleich sagen das interessiert
mich auch bringen und zwar hast du schon
mal erotische filme geschaut er sich
jetzt auf 3 12 ich bin ja überlegen
haben wir den dritten habe ich auch
geguckt
ja aber es geht ja jetzt natürlich gut
das kann man auch als erotische bilder
film es geht ja ich glaube hier in
erster linie auch um also ich hab das
meiste davon aus dem internet kopiert um
eigentlich nicht um ehrlich zu sein
wieso man kriegt ja immer diese pubs und
da sieht man das natürlich also aber
sagen wir so früh legalen seiten
unterwegs nicht so ich bin dran
jetzt gibt es das ganze brett ist voller
extreme alles andere was würdest du
gerne mal ausprobieren traust dich aber
nicht hast du schon mal eine straftat
begangen ich glaube ich habe ich jetzt
einen kleinen fehler gemacht weil
eigentlich werden dass zwei weißt du was
würdest du gerne mal ausprobieren traust
dich aber nicht nee jetzt beantworte ich
einfach dass für den fall darauf
gelandet ist also hast du schon mal eine
straftat begangen
das jetzt natürlich schwierig zu sagen
weil ich habe schon einige straftaten
gemacht da war ich allerdings immer
unter 14
wo man ist ja erst mit 14 sowie strafen
in dich also ich habe früher haben wir
einmal an einer tankstelle capri-sonne
geklappt und wir haben auch wirklich
sehr sehr auf so hausfriedensbruch
begangen das wäre einfach in anderen
gärten warum auch immer wir haben früher
immer so ein spiel gespielt da musste
man durch fremde gärten laufen und der
der die meisten fremden gärten
hintereinander durchlaufen hat hat am
ende gewonnen und haltung aber das war
so unsere tages beschäftigung du bist
ein richtig schlimmer sagt ach so ich
würde sagen jeder der fünf werten okay
du triffst ja irgendwie immer wenn es
hier den nächsten wurf und zwar hast du
schon mal ins waschbecken gepinkelt so
dazu kann ich erst mal sagen dass alex
immer zu mir das spaß sagt in zwei
stücken pinkl aber nein ich hab
natürlich noch nicht etwa schmecken und
winkel wie soll das auch gehen als
mädchen
da müsste man sich draufsetzen können
sollen er war habe ich hier nicht
gemacht aber alex bestimmt ja habe ich
schon gemacht ja ja ja wenn die toilette
besetzt war oder verstopft oder so ist
dann kann man doch auch mal ins lot
bringen aber das sehen wir einmal war
ich im urlaub und dann habe ich so ein
waschbecken mit dem stegreif verwechseln
weil das das war zwar kein steak aber
dass ich wusste auch nichts anderes als
totaler genau das ist für die füße aber
ich habe früher einmal gedacht das wäre
das steak und spanien das die dadurch
gestellt okay ich bin dran
alex hat sodass der getroffen und zwar
auf einer skala von eins
wie gut aussehen hältst du dich ja es
war klar
auf einer skala von das ist wirklich
eine sehr gemeine frage aber ich finde
man ist es wichtig selbst bewusst zu
sein ich sage jetzt nicht zehn ich sag
mal so gut
so leute marie wir hatten doch kein
einziges mal pflicht oder ok du wirst ja
nicht mal angekommen so maria zweimal
hintereinander nicht getroffen aber der
dritte hat gesessen und zwar was findest
du an der person neben dir besonders
schön da jetzt nur zu zweit spielen was
findest du denn an mir besonders schön
also soll ich dir sagen was ich an alle
allerschönster in der kunde keine ahnung
alex augen sind um alle schützen oder
also ich finde jetzt sexy blick in die
kamera also ich finde jetzt nicht so
besonders
sie sind ein okay was sagen wie lange
sind ja das würde ich jetzt verstanden
wenn du gesagt hast du hast richtig
coole wimpern
ich hätte auch gern so lange wimpern wie
du weil ich krieg vorlauf gesagt von
mädchen auch dass die gerne so lange
wimpern hätten wir ja aber es geht ja
nicht darum so was ich gerne hätte von
dein aussehen geht ihr darum was nicht
wird zur nächsten feier local ja gibt
eine erotik kontaktanzeige auch alex
dann muss ich sagen das finde ich
eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht das
wollte ich schon immer mal wieder machen
problem ist jetzt nur wo soll ich das
denn machen sowie eine erotik
kontaktanzeige ja aber da ist schon
damit dating plattform mit gemeint so
app store leute ich würde sagen ich mach
das mal kurz und du darfst eigentlich
schon den nächsten fall werfen okay so
alex macht gerade die da wo
kontaktanzeige und ich habe gerade
geworfen was findest du an die am
schönsten und was am hässlichsten also
was finde ich am hässlichsten war nicht
schön am hässlichsten finde ich meine
füße vor allen dingen weil ich jetzt
1000 blasen an den füßen habe und am
schönsten an
ich glaube ich meinen hund also meine
lippen er warte mal ich bin jetzt hier
mit london sollte ich könnte euch jetzt
mal moment so leute ich bin jetzt fertig
mit meinem account und zwar ich bin hier
der alex 20 jahre alt wohnt in köln
hätte gibt es auch noch alles richtig
jan willst du sie damit wirklich
irgendwann klar dann habe ich
geschrieben über mich männlich hübsch
ladies meldet auf der suche nach frauen
18 bis 30 jahre interessiert an
bekanntschaften dates aussehen
ein mit 81 athletisch keine kinder kein
raucher und ich habe das ja es war ein
profilbild gewählt dann habe ich noch
diese fotos hochgeladen
und ich möchte mich dann im nächsten
video wie ist denn hier wieder neue
leute bei 20.000 mache ich einen extra
video was denn hier so abgeht anflügen
so leute ich bin wieder dran der runde
nicht einfach zwei runden hintereinander
pflicht geworfen
ich bin mir schon dass das kommt ja okay
vielleicht tue ist wieder dran
entweder man eigentlich darf hier noch
einmal werden da haben wir schon fünf
brauche dann darfst du noch zweimal
werfen was findest du aber das hattest
du schon wenn wir noch mal was ist das
dümmste was du je getan hast so marie
wird was ist das dümmste dass du je
getan hast weil ich gar nicht auf anhieb
man sorgt eine von den vielen dummen
sachen im kindergarten habe ich meiner
besten freundin einen hocker auf den
kopf gehauen aber so richtig weil
nämlich nicht mitspielen lassen dann
aber sie ist immer noch meine besten
grüße gehen raus annehme
ich habe auch mal im kindergarten jemand
runter geschubst von seinem großen ding
und der ist toll auf dem kopf geflogen
und da ist nichts schlimmeres passiert
eigentlich näher nele hat so ein kleines
loch im kopf aber so leute mein letzter
wurde soll ich machen mit augen zu
werfen es ist noch nicht getroffen
schicke da im letzten rennabschnitt ein
herz egal wer alex abgeworfen schicke
deinem letzten mossad ein herz egal wer
hoffentlich glaube das habe ich von
bravo
da waren nämlich nur so scheiße wo
gerade hier wo jetzt premium mitglied
werden ich glaube das mache ich doch
schon jetzt eigentlich gar kein problem
das soll jetzt hier zwei gruppen der
oberste ist jetzt therapie
hier was ich machen musste dass jetzt
noch einmal werfen nicht so der letzte
wurf von mario back to the roots würden
sagen
[Musik]
tausche mit einer person des anderen
geschlechts die kleidung muss man sich
an ein muss das kleid janssen aber das
ist ja jetzt eigentlich schlecht für
mich und meine schlappen die auf meine
schlappen aber das ist ja voll dumm dass
das ist jetzt für mich schlecht obwohl
das ist auch ein bisschen mehr es geht
sogar ja dachte ich mal gerade damit man
auch schöner ausschnitt sie die arbeite
das was mit dieser wunderbaren challenge
wahrheit oder pflicht ich hoffe
natürlich das video hat euch gefallen
lassen könnten nach oben da muss noch
einmal auf die schuhe film warten
nein das sieht ja hier diese schule
schaut auf jeden fall bei instagram
vorbei und wir sehen uns morgen wieder
da jetzt ein neues cooles video dann
auch wieder ohne kleid